i stand before you to officially launch
my campaign
for a second term i accept this
nomination
for president of the united states of
america more than 1900 people in the u.s
have died
historic mega fires more than 38 million
people have now lost their jobs
i don't want to put my mouse that mask
is killing people socialism is nothing
but communism
nationwide outrage
we are as close to a cultural civil war
as we have been since uh the 1860s
success
is going to bring us together we are on
the road to success
we are in the battle of the soul of this
nation
hello my name is ak i'm a business owner
i'm also a father and i am currently
a registered independent but leaning
democrat hey my name is mike i am a
member of the walk away movement which
is people who have walked away from the
left in the democratic party
so i consider myself kind of part of the
new right my name is shai
i am an educator and i am
a liberal who leans more so in the
middle
my name is maggie i'm a data analyst i'm
independent but a lot of my issues do
line up with the conservative point of
view my name is joe i work in democratic
politics i actually just
recently worked for elizabeth warren's
presidential campaign and
ironically i grew up in a very
conservative family my name is amy
i am a veteran and a mom of three boys
i'm a registered independent but i tend
to lean conservative
if you disagree with the statement
please turn your camera
off the united states
is the greatest country on earth
when i think about america being the
greatest country one of those benefits
that i do think is so great is we have
the freedom of choice
there's many countries where women their
voices are suppressed
um even typing our thoughts on the
internet that's suppressed
i really truly fully believe that
america is really the last standing
pillar of democracy as a whole
in the entire world right now when it
comes to the people having the choice on
what direction this country goes
right now especially in 2020 i feel like
we're personally the only country left
where we have that opportunity and that
door open for us
the united states is actually the only
country that has freedom of speech in
its constitution
and i think most people would agree like
without freedom of speech like you can't
do much like that is really pretty key
having like freedom of thought and like
people being able to like make
to criticize the government and make
changes for the better if you look at
other western countries that we think of
as being free countries they're really
not anymore i mean in the uk
you have comedians being put on trial
for jokes and given
prison sentences in canada there have
been people put on trial for
criticizing different politics
so for me i would say that depending on
what statistics you want to use
in america there's more people in prison
there's
more people have guns in this country
than anywhere around around the world
i think there's other places that also
have democracy there's other places that
also have opportunity
and it's not just the united states by
turning my camera off i did not want to
come off as saying i don't think america
is a good place or it's not
it could ever be the greatest place i
just think in this moment it's not the
greatest place this country is the worst
country when it comes to
covet response it's not just because we
have so many people it's because we're
doing almost
nothing outside of a few democratic
states to combat it i had kovit back in
march
um during the you know a huge outbreak
in new york city where we literally had
refrigerated trucks sitting in hospitals
because the morgues were full
we don't know the long-term effects of
this disease and we've unfortunately
made the debate
about deaths versus not but the reality
is it's a disease
and it's wrecking havoc on people's
bodies and we should just be really
careful about not letting millions of
people get it but i just want to push
back on this idea that uh a lot of
people say president trump hasn't done
anything he's neglected it kamala harris
just the other day released a statement
saying that president trump found out on
january 28th about covet and he did
nothing he found out on the 28th and
then on january 29th he established the
task force
uh the u.s coronavire task force on
january 30th he closed the border to
china
against what every democrat wanted they
called it xenophobic they called him a
racist they said he was hysterical and
through
all of february every leading democrat
was saying
go out to parades go to chinatown it's
nothing to worry about i'm in new york
our governor cuomo put covid patients in
nursing homes
which is basically a death sentence when
we know that that's the most vulnerable
population
one thing that i was kind of glad to see
with trump
was i would say he took a fairly
libertarian approach to
how he handled coronavirus even though
he wanted states to open back up he did
not force them to do so
even though he wasn't a fan of mask
mandates he didn't
bar states from from doing mass mandates
and if you look at the coverage of
coronavirus it's often talking about
like
new york did it this way florida did it
this way
texas did it this way it's often talking
about it at a state level so i do see
that as a win
in terms of like trump left the decision
up to the states this is not a one
person takes all the blame situation you
know
there was a lot of slow moving parts by
the mayor and the governor of new york
state
that made everything worse there's no
question about that but at the end of
the day
when the governor can't manufacture or
acquire
personal protective equipment for an
outbreak they can't get enough
ventilators
they can't roll out a contact tracing
program so they don't have the money for
it
you know at some point the federal
government has to take blame for that
for what is happening
here in america new zealand went over
100 days without a single case and
that's not because they have a low
population
they just did really basic stuff they
said wear a mask if you get infected
let's find out who you met with let's
find out what friends and family you're
with
and let's tell them to isolate for a few
days it doesn't take a ton of
money it just takes leadership to say
let's do this in every single state
i think we should take this virus
seriously however i am also worried
about
protecting our rights in the meantime
because this is reminding me a lot of
911 in that
9 11 was obviously something that was
very real and affect everybody
but because everybody was so afraid at
that time the government was able to
come in
and impede on all of our rights and
anyone who tried to speak up for our
constitutional rights
was called anti-american and you're with
the terrorists and i feel like that's
kind of what happened what is happening
now if anyone
wants to consider what the other damage
that is being done
in fighting the coronavirus you're told
you just want to kill grandmothers and
you're not taking it seriously so i
think that needs to be a balance
in how we approach this i'll agree with
mikey in terms of
the economic response business has been
shutting down and
people are trying to find ways to
support themselves and their families
in addition we can also talk about
donald trump just
two days before he got kobut was on
stage making fun of joe biden
about wearing a mask right this is the
leader of the country so we can't also
say that he took it seriously
and then at the same time was mocking
somebody for taking it seriously
mikey you touched on you know civil
liberties especially after 9 11. look i
wholeheartedly agree the patriot act and
a lot that came from that was a mistake
to me
asking someone to wear a mask and
potentially having an app on their phone
that does
non-gps-based contact tracing that's not
really privacy invasive or taking away
my rights that's just like
basic respect and humanity to like
protect others we're not taking guns
away we're not reading your sms
messages like i think i think you're
kind of stretching the truth there those
are absolutely things that are
happening that government is reading
messages buying us listen to anything
that edward snowden has to say so
right that's what they did then but
that's not what's happening now
of course it's still happening we're
still 20 years later trying to
i'm talking about undo all the power
that the government took in 2001.
as uh their measures keep getting more
draconian it's not going to they aren't
going to then relinquish this power
but what power they get by asking me to
wear a mask like it's a very
simple thing in california where they're
saying where the governor said that
they'll shut off people's power
if they have more than six people over
their apartment i don't think that's the
place of the government i'm just saying
a basic statement
like wear a mask when you're going
grocery shopping to protect everyone
around you like i think we can all agree
that that's a good idea and that's not
intruding on my rights and the president
should encourage people to do so as a
the leader of the country
talking about you know a government
impeding on somebody's rights we have
the speed limits we have
laws that we have to obey every single
day we're not in this place where it's
complete
anarchy where we can do whatever we want
to so every single day the government is
enforcing rules and regulations
that we decide to follow but if now a
mask is something that's so big
i think it's just a little bit of a
stretch
the other side circulates more fake
news
when we talk about fake news especially
when we're or
in my case when i'm thinking of the
other side fox news is like
the first one that comes to mind a lot
of the things that they say
to me tries to instill fear it's the
rhetoric that they use
to try to get people angry or anxious
about the opposite side's views
me being an independent i listen to
everybody so i'll listen to fox
but i you know here and there i will
listen to cnn okay what's cnn saying
what's that
msnbc saying and stuff the negativity
like i don't know how anybody could
watch those on a day-to-day basis
and feel hopeful i find this question a
little bit challenging because i think
both sides
have i guess the word fake news that's
going out there but the reason i find it
difficult is because
fake news never started until this
administration
the biggest fake news that i would say
is them saying that the economy
is now saved under trump what are those
facts though because for me personally
when i look at the trade deals that he
did
with the united states canada mexico
agreement and everything there are trade
deals that he trump has
implemented in his administration that
have been very very effective
if you really look at the jobs that are
being created right now in this country
under a pandemic
no that's pretty i'm a nancy pelosi
clapped that one that's pretty damn
impressive to me
talking about the economy improving it
was already improving
before he got into office you look at
2010 in october the unemployment rate
nationally was a 10 and by january 2017
when a
trump got into office it was at 4.7 the
weekly earnings rate was already
improving
the stock market was already the highest
it was ever been in 2013.
i would give this a trump he is an
amazing marketer
obama wasn't putting on twitter every
single day that the stock market was the
highest it's ever been in 2013
and off you said uh that fake news
didn't really exist before this
administration
is crazy to me i mean even think back to
the iraq war
who sold the iraq war to the american
people it was the new york times
the hysteria about trump i think
is totally unjustified there was a study
from harvard showing that 94
of media coverage of trump is negative
there was a time that trump was asked
about ms-13 a gang which beheads people
and murders children and he called them
animals
the new york times the media the entire
mainstream media cnn they all reported
that
trump called all immigrants animals they
said he called neo-nazis in
charlottesville good people but they
clip out the middle of his sentence
where he said
i'm not talking about the neo-nazis and
white supremacists who should be
condemned totally so you know i think at
this point everybody knows what they're
getting when they watch fox news it's a
conservative channel
and i feel like they don't really
pretend to be anything but that the
problem is that every other channel is
fox news but for the left
i agree with you the new york times sold
the iraq war and like the mainstream
media was complicit in selling those
lies that's 100 true
but there's a huge monumental difference
between what fox
and certain right-wing pundits do with
media the new york times if they get a
story wrong
if they publish misinformation on
accident like they issue retractions
journalists get fired editors get fired
i know this because i know people who
work at these media companies
and in terms of expertise we also need
to touch on this fox news does not bring
experts on its show they don't bring
climate scientists on their show to talk
about climate change
the new york times actually employs
people with deep understandings of all
these subject areas
i don't think the new york times these
organizations are perfect at covering
politics
at the end of the day they do care about
truth the people there do care about you
i totally disagree with that i mean
there have been so many studies showing
that the vast vast vast majority of
people employed in mainstream media are
all democrats i mean show me
well show me where they've retracted
saying that trump called immigrants
animals show me where they've retracted
saying that he called nazis very fine
people show me where they retracted that
he didn't con
that he hasn't condoned white supremacy
i just saw somebody put together
uh a tweet from cnn that said from 2017
that says trump condones white suprema
or uh condemns white supremacy and says
racism is evil and then a tweet from
last week saying trump has never
condemned white supremacy so they're not
retracting any of this
i don't remember the past four years in
great detail because it's been a long
time it's felt like 10 years let's be
real
oh please we all need to drink after
this decade so let's go with the most
recent example in memory
which is the debate he's asked very
plainly as a presidential candidate
regardless of party can you condemn the
extremist people in this country
who literally hate and want to kill and
harm other people that should be the
easiest
toss for any political candidate to do
and he answered
the affirmative yeah he said he said he
did not
stand back and stand by no he said sure
sure and then after that he then said
well look at antifa and all those other
people he actually switched the blame
this was not something that we saw
after the fact we saw this live
happening he didn't say white supremacy
is a good thing
he didn't avoid trying to condemn white
supremacy as soon as he was asked like
will you condemn wipes
white supremacy he answered in the
affirmative like he said show her he
said sure multiple times chris wallace
said like will you ask them to
stand down i think and so trump used the
word stand by which most people
like take to mean kind of like be on the
ready and i'm sure you guys all watched
the debate um but i would say that if
you go back and watch the entire clip
leading up to that
i would say it's pretty hard to deny
that trump was saying like yes i will
disavow white supremacy
but as a leader we should know that we
do need to be careful in those moments
when
seven million or how many ever millions
of people are watching this on that
platform
that we use those words correctly it
makes me afraid to leave my home it
makes me think well
they are being supported by him and they
want to
push whatever he wants them to do so
even just thinking about those terms
um and even kind of bringing it more so
towards like my local city
when we think about media and what they
want to put on tv
and what they want to put in the
headlines i was a part of
almost too many peaceful protests that
not one camera
was around uh but as soon as you saw
people getting a little angry and they
were breaking into stores and they were
looting
the cameras was there so i do definitely
say media has an impact on how we hear
and receive things
but also as a leader the leaders need to
know that the media
is going to use your words against you
you do need to say certain things more
direct or more assertive
to make sure everybody understands on
that first day not
two days later or 12 hours later
whatever the case might be
i completely agree even as a trump
supporter look when
i voted for trump me personally i voted
for trump in 2016.
and i knew back then he's not a
politician
he's gonna say some things that the
media who already hates his guts
is going to take some things and and
twist it so i agree and when i was
watching that debate
and joe biden was all like proud boys
you know what i mean
why doesn't he just say hey i literally
just made the kkk
a terrorist organization that right
there you're disavowing white supremacy
i wish he would have said that instead
of saying the stand back and stand by
things
responsible for talking about what you
were saying shy is i feel terrible that
you would
watch that and get that impression i
think that that's a total failure of the
trump campaign you know
just between us i was watching the
debate and screaming at my tv
why aren't you talking about the things
that you've done it was so infuriating
to me
i hated trump in 2016. i didn't vote for
him
i thought every horrible thing about him
and one of the things that really
changed my mind is when i saw
the things that he was actually doing to
help the black community
when you see what he has done for the
black community when it's the
opportunity zones whether it's the
previous reform whether it's fighting
for school choice was girl that helps
those black single mothers that are out
there in the community who live
in these impoverished zones and
everything their children aren't
sentenced
into really schools and everything
excuse my friendship to me him doing
things like that
is so that we can bring it up oh but he
did do this for the black community
oh he did do this so that's what it
feels like and as far as like
a school choice um as an educator
that literally almost can demolish the
public school system
why not fix the public schools that are
currently crumbling
why not provide extra funding to those
schools why is it that those students
have to rely on schools
just for food you know i'm teaching out
of a textbook from 2008
so it literally does not even have obama
in that textbook
president trump is not in that textbook
so yes he has plans that have helped the
black community
but i think it is a cop to say yes i've
helped the black community in this way
but i'm still not going to tell them
proud boys to leave you all alone
i am worried about a civil war in this
country
i don't think it'll be a civil war the
way we think of it on battlefields but i
think in many ways it's already
happening i think no matter who wins the
election
no one's going to accept it there's
going to be rioting there's going to be
everything regardless of what happens
it should be a real priority for a lot
of people calming things down
we are going to most definitely i
believe
have some bloodshed after the election i
do not think it's going to be like you
said mikey
um on a battlefield but i feel like it
will happen
in in communities there's hundreds of
militias
around the country and i think we're
only focusing on one ignoring that there
are these chapters that are in every
single state
around the country the boogaloo movement
for example has had dozens of people
arrested this year alone by the fbi
because they've shot police officers
they've shot at protesters they've
planted
or tried to plan bombings and just the
other week we learned they tried to
kidnap a governor of a state there are
people
out there who are genuinely trying to do
more than just punch someone or whatever
in the street they are going for full-on
like biggest possible show of violence
you can go for
and i'm far more worried about at-level
extremism
than i am about the prout boys and my
problems with biden
but after trump got coveted he didn't
bash
the first lady or trump he said this
is not a right issue or a left issue
this is an american issue
i have never seen that coming from
donald trump and that is what i worry
about the most
is that i don't feel like donald trump
will be able to
calm the nation if something does happen
i definitely agree with you ak
um just the once again like i said a
little bit earlier just the rhetoric
that he uses is gonna cause some people
to get angry he hasn't
to my knowledge actually said if he's
going to
accept on the results of the election
which also of course would make some
liberals a little upset
if you know the numbers are adding up
and the electoral college votes and
we've got 270 and he still refuses to
accept that it makes people feel like
they might have to result
uh to violence in order to remove him
from office
you know we talked earlier about how
he's kind of a showman he wasn't a
politician he doesn't know the words
this is a moment probably more than ever
in my lifetime and all of our lifetimes
where words are going to really really
matter
they're convincing their supporters the
whole thing will be raped
so no matter what happens they shouldn't
accept it
it's not going to be long before the
tiki tur torches turn to guns and people
shooting at each other like we saw in
kenosha wisconsin
that was unfortunately two people's
lives lost what happens when it's 30
when it's 50.
how much violence you're gonna be able
to tolerate in this country some people
say what carbon house
did was murder the other side is looking
at him as a hero
and that is what the scary part to me is
i'm not saying he's a hero but what are
you supposed to do when you have people
attacking you charging you with guns and
are
about to shoot you i don't think he
should have been there he came across
state lines with an ar-15 to a protest
like you asked for problems just being
there you shouldn't have been there i go
very back and forth
on how i feel about this with trump
because i certainly wish he would be
more unifying
and i don't love everything he has to
say but
on the other side right now every
institution in this country is on the
side of democrats and on the side of the
left and he's pushing back against that
and without that i don't think that
anyone else would
i wish that he would be clearer about
the results of the election but i do
think
mail and ballots are the most
susceptible to fraud we shouldn't
we should just keep things how they've
been colorado has been a state that's
voted almost
entirely by mail now for years they have
no fraud
right like doing vote by mail fraud is
extremely hard because
those ballots are unique and if there's
any allegations of fraud
they still compare signatures just like
you would with in-person ballots
democrats i believe was in california
wanted to get rid of signature
verification it was racist to have your
id at a voting poll all of a sudden
if we're being honest how many of us
really know what extent of integrity
there
are in the elections there were a lot of
shady things happening in
the midterms in 2018 in broward county
in florida there was a woman
who had been convicted of destroying
ballots and she's still now in charge of
handling the ballots so i think
there's a lot of blame on both sides as
ak said but
my question to you mike is if trump wins
the election do you think he's still
going to be
pushing for fraud no i mean i think we
see what happens i think it depends
on the fact that there is any he's only
going to push for fraud
if a liberal candidate wins but if he
wins
everything we can trust it is great that
is an issue
i was thinking civil war in the
traditional sense and so for me it's
very hard to imagine people
physically getting organized and
battling
over the territory of the country i do
think that the country
is divided i don't necessarily think
that that's anything super new
you know elections have always been
pretty 50 50. so i think that's a really
great reason
why it makes a lot of sense to move
decisions away from the federal and
national level and move decisions to the
state level
because i think that's one of the best
ways to be an option for people who
disagree to still live in the same
country
i did have kind of a story to give
regarding mail-in voting
and whether or not it is corruptable i
have two roommates
and i know that they're not voting the
same way i am and
i received both of their mail-in ballots
i have integrity like i just gave it to
each of them
but the thought did occur to me like
somebody who could justify that to
themselves
could either a throw away their ballots
or they could be
fill them out for their candidate of
choice and mail them back if we're
talking about not accepting the results
of an election i feel like
democrats still have barely accepted the
results of the last one they've said for
so long he's not a legitimate president
russia put him there
i feel like democrats like to talk about
a lot about democracy but they're the
ones
who have shown a pattern of not
accepting it they're the ones who rigged
their primary against bernie sanders in
the 2016
primary they threw voters off the rolls
they destroyed two hundred thousand or
abouts they took took 200 000 voters off
the rolls in bernie sanders own
hometown so i think there's a lot of
blame on both sides in this and that
everyone only likes the outcome of an
election when it suits them
i 100 agreed to maggie's point and also
mike's i actually do feel the
mail-in voting is actually hurting more
liberals and democrats
because if everybody would just to go to
the polls then there won't be this
hard transition of of transfer of power
in addition we are very divided and
this didn't just come in this particular
not accepting the president i think it
was in 2010 or
mitch mcconnell went on the floor and
said i'm going to make sure that
obama is a one-term president at that
moment when he stood there and said this
i'm not going to make him the one-term
president it no longer was for the good
of the country
it then became the good of the party i
totally agree with you i think
republicans were disgusting under obama
and
i feel the same way about democrats now
i can understand why someone would vote
for the other candidate
as far as like the trying to understand
why someone would vote for trump people
trust him as far as like being a
businessman
um and trying to restructure our economy
in that way so that i do understand
but then my rebuttal for that is we
don't necessarily need a business man
for america we need a leader
i can definitely see why someone would
vote for joe biden in particular or a
democrat in general
it's not necessarily like that people
like him it's that they more identify as
a democrat i also want to say like all
the people that i've met that are voting
for biden
like are all good people they're doing
the best they can with what they've got
like i think that goes for all of us
i could understand what people would
vote for trump i think the bigger
question is are you surprised about who
would be voting for trump there's
certain populations that make sense if
you're in business
if you do feel like you've been
forgotten by
the democratic party i could understand
it's not actually just voting for trump
it'd be voting for trump
be voting for his cabinet the same thing
with biden or his cabinet i think it's
more than just voting for the people
but about the constituents that they
bring along with their team
i'm looking at it from a national
security standpoint the ccp
is a very very large threat to me um
and my family and everything and the joe
biden when you have your son that has
received 1.5 billion dollars
and and unfortunately it's not
conspiracy anymore i can't expect you to
protect us as american people i can't
understand why you would vote for
somebody
who won't have our best interest who is
flip-flopping
constantly on whether it's fracking
whether
it's uh your support for long order
whether it's your support
for things that are the foundation not
the racist foundation not that
not the past you know but you know the
the actual
constitutional bill of rights foundation
if it were
anyone else i would really truly say i
totally get it i totally understand why
somebody would vote for
hillary for bernie sanders for elizabeth
warren
i don't get it with joe biden we'll talk
about the system as racist
joe biden is the system he created he
was an architect of so many of these
things mass incarceration the war on
drugs the 94 crime bill
he wrote laws where he literally said on
the senate floor
the only thing we do not do in this bill
is hang people for jaywalking i said
this earlier when we were chatting
informally i worked on warren's campaign
obviously i wanted her to win right
biden wasn't my guy
and he still says things that
disappointment you know you brought up
fracking
i wish he was against fracking but he
hasn't flipped on it what disappoints me
a lot more
than biden's maybe not perfect
progressive stances
is what trump is doing right now he
wants to kick me off of health care the
republican party right now has a lawsuit
and it wants to completely invalidate
the aca which means someone like me
under 26 that's a freelancer
doesn't get to use their parents health
care plan it means people that are on
the health care exchanges right now
because of medicaid expansion all across
this country
instantly off of health care and the
difference between trump and joe biden
is joe biden has a plan to continue the
aca make a public option to continue to
make health care more affordable
he has a plan for climate change he has
a plan for a criminal justice
you might think both of those things are
inadequate or they might not address
whatever the problems
but the point is he has a plan and he's
willing to listen to people to make that
plan better i want joe biden to be more
progressive
and i'll fight him after november if he
wins to make him more progressive
if there's anyone in the year of 2020
that could be a leader in this moment
where we are all experiencing so much
national trauma both
locally when we can't even go to
funerals for our loved ones
but also just seeing so many beloved
people die this year if there's anyone
that understands or has
any empathy for what we're all going
through it's joe biden
and donald trump has put no empathy on
display
this guy got out of the hospital
immediately took off his mask and said
don't worry about it it's fine
that's not what we need right now the
aca was a very double-edged
sword it's not about whether you have
health care or don't have health care
trump has always said that he is in
favor of uh outlawing the pre-existing
condition law
and the thing is the aca didn't work so
well the aca didn't hasn't worked so
well for all of us my parents are both
cancer survivors their insurance got so
much more expensive
they lost their insurance because of it
my mom is a survivor of brain cancer
who lost the doctor that put her in
remission because of the aca
so i understand that there are good
things about it and believe me i totally
want republicans to be much better on
health care because you're right i agree
with you that they i don't know what
they are for half the time and for me i
know this is going to be a very
unpopular thing to say
and this isn't going to be any
popularity points but honestly
i don't care about empathy right now i
will care about action
i don't care about feelings and words i
care about actions who has done it and
joe biden has just been so much talk
with no action to back it up when you're
in office for half a century
you should be about more than words you
should have a record to run on
i can understand somebody saying that
joe biden sucks i can understand that
but to then say that the republican
party is the solution is where i'm just
flabbergasted by because they're doing
nothing other than
throw money on top and then bury you
from the bottom
just like saying diversity training is
un-american
you mean just shy say that it was
critical race theory okay
so i don't consider that the republican
party is doing anything better to court
voters only during election time i
totally agree
and i would say for me there is a huge
difference between the republican party
party and trump when i first heard that
donald trump was running for running for
president
i laughed but one of the things that
made me start to give it a second look
was the fact that
both parties were seeking to tear him
down so much so you're saying that
you're more
you're more in support of trump than the
republican party
at this point yeah and like one thing
that comes to mind that i guess really
shocked me and disappointed me
was joe biden's comment several months
ago essentially saying
that if you were a black person that you
had to vote for joe biden and if anybody
said like because you're a white person
you have to vote for trump or because
you're a woman you have to vote for joe
biden i would be extremely offended and
i think that's
incredibly divisive that's one of the
issues that i do see with the democratic
party because they are stereotypically
the party of the minorities they do
think they just
automatically have you know minority
votes just as
upset i was when you know trump makes
his
comments i was also upset when you know
joe biden said that as well we can't
just automatically assume
we have those voices because yeah black
people stereotypically are
democrat or more liberal and so on that
was a joke he made
and he apologized for doing it because i
thought it was inappropriate and like he
immediately apologizes it was
inappropriate i should have made that
joke right and i think it's a big
difference between trump and biden
jokes are usually a reflection of the
truth and
you know they love to use this term a
gaff but i think a gaffe is really when
a politician accidentally says what they
really think
and he didn't even say if you don't vote
for him he said if a black person asks
questions about voting for him then they
ain't black you know the reason why i
have an issue with donald trump for a
myriad of different reasons
the thing that he lacks is diplomacy
and i think within the right they think
that the only way to get stuff done
is to be brash and disrespectful you
don't have to be there's a point about
actual civility you can actually not
talk trash anybody and still get jobs
done
and then people wonder why we're so
divided but i think we should also
remember
the economy has actually done better
under democratic rule does anybody
remember what happened in 2008
it's like we almost forget that we're in
a recession it's almost like we forgot
that the unemployment rate did drop
under obama we also remember about
climate change
um wall street reform daca right so
you're trying to pretend
that he hasn't done anything this was
just on the prior
presidency where he was a vice president
that people are pretending
didn't happen i think if we're going to
talk about the recession let's look at
what joe biden
has done because he's the one who is
actually on the ballot he when he was in
the senate he removed protections that
had been in place since
fdr on the big banks there was the
bankruptcy bill which allowed the banks
to become too big to fail and cost
middle-class people to lose their home
and we all remember that hillary clinton
was caught saying about a public
position in a private position
well we have 47 years of seeing what joe
biden's private
positions are if you look at his actual
actions and i totally agree with you
that i
very much wish trump would be more
unifying and would be less bombastic but
i think
his he gets results but at what cost
how many times has trump put more
fire more gas in the fire when the nfl
protests were happening
he could have just said hey i'm gonna
step out of it but he had to go out
there and say
these sobs right how many times has he
actually not been unified i would
actually say the biggest
problem that we're facing today is we
can't listen to each other
if you can't listen to each other i
don't care who you're going to have in
office
it's going to be continually fighting
back and forth and what i've seen from
the republican base literally letting
anything go yeah biden isn't the best he
gasps
he's not my most exciting choice but
we're not also saying that he's also
anointed from god in the best presence
we've ever seen
that is the difference we understand
that he has problems
but we also understand that trump has
problems as well and we want to say
we're not going in the right direction
where things are going me personally i
feel like trump's
problems are in a weird ironic way
a blessing at the same time so one of
the things he's not a politician
therefore he's not going to be
politically correct
i know i completely understand that it's
not going to be necessarily
the best or the most popular thing to
say but it's something that needs to
still be
said um
i'm just saying this like all these
things are politically correct there's
difference between just
outright making fun of every single
candidate he's a business man he's been
on tv it's not like he's a
toddler when it comes to this
establishment that has been running
especially if you want to look at the
black community specifically
the things that they have had in place
the things that they've been
regurgitating
and been feeding us as a black community
as a whole i feel like those things need
to be broken
where's joe biden whether it's obama
whether it's hillary clinton
or there's a whole little family you
know that has been saying what we want
to hear
to get them voted into office to run
policies that do absolutely nothing for
the black community
as a whole but that's just not true i
mean when we talk about if we're going
to continue to put black people and say
they're a monolith
lgbt climate change these are all i
understand that i'm not
i'm not defending joe biden i'm just
saying it's not like trump is the savior
of black people
one thing is i find it also very
insulting when people think the only
black issues are crime bills
right that is like insulting to think
that the black is just related to crime
when you think about black america
we are not a monolith right lgb2
climate change daca all these other
things that happened
under obama right that build out the
auto industry black unemployment rate
was at what 17
in 2010 and got down to 7.6 and i just
want people to always think that
black problems are only crime issues
because that is insulting as
as a population i think there's so much
more than we are than just
prison systems um i mean just real quick
on education stuff we were talking about
earlier
um i think it's a national problem and
we really needed a national
solution what i've seen from betsy devos
is someone that
really tries to play this divisive line
that really has no interest in
growing public public education and
making sure that every child has the
best possible education and i think
again joe biden is not perfect but i
know he'll appoint a great secretary of
education
i know he's going to take public schools
seriously and that benefits all of us
when the generation behind us has a
great education
when i think of the state that i live in
and i
look at the school systems that we have
it is specifically
republican legislation that has led to
the decline and the defunding of our
public schools
when we look at joe biden's plan they're
saying look on day one
we plan on giving title 1 schools x
amount of money
so especially when i think of public
education and we've talked about school
choice before but we have to fix what is
available to all of our students at this
point in time
i don't really have faith in republicans
to truly support
public education and to support the
needs of people
if we think of our public schools they
get money based off of like the tax
dollars from the neighborhoods that you
live in
poor neighborhoods are going to get
little funding rich neighborhoods are
going to get more funding
republicans have done nothing to stop
this but say you know what that's okay
let's still give these corporations a
tax cut and not let them pay an extra
penny so that maybe that money could go
to our public schools
i do think that public school is not the
same as education
um and i think that if we're thinking
about the good of students in general
choice and competition is extremely
important in any system when you
introduce competition
almost always quality goes up and cost
goes down and so i think we're doing a
disservice to our kids
if we're not giving them choices and if
we're not allowing competition in
education
sometimes what happens with this
competition is there's still
only a small subgroup of students that
are actually able to choose
when we think of school choice and we
say yeah we're going to open it up
they're still going to be stuck in
public schools who have now been left
behind
because we've given them a choice to go
somewhere else and we've created this
competition
sure i think that even if it just
benefits a small segment of children
i think that's still valuable i mean i
think the public school system
is obviously it's something that's been
a challenge for a very long time and
think of people are trying to find
solutions but like i said i think both
parties have done things but i think our
decisions that while we're making these
voting decisions are multifaceted right
i think both sides have done more for
the black community my personal feeling
is
the way that the republican party
represents the black community
isn't always the best this is going to
sound very counterintuitive because i
know his words can be
a little insane but i genuinely truly
believe that trump has
totally changed the republican party i
hated the old republican party
like and all of those old republicans
that are still around they got to go
we've had so many years of the
republican party ignoring the black
community
worse than ignoring the gay community
and i think trump has totally changed
that he's brought lgbt groups into the
white house
he has done so many things the role that
many of us
in the party now need to have is to keep
that ball rolling and keep
changing a party that has sucked for so
many years
i am open to the other party's ideas
i think i would do a huge disservice if
i did not listen to the other side
especially in my role i don't want to
ever go into the classroom with just
this
one opinion and not being able to listen
to my other students or parents
or administrators and leaders who have
different viewpoints too
i'm part of the walk away movement of
people who used to be democrats and have
left
one of the things i always say to them
is do not become what you walked away
from so i think the worst thing we could
do is buy into tribalism and
group thing i've been a democrat i've
been an independent now i'm a republican
so for me personally
the moment that the republican party no
longer represents what i think is best
for my country and my values i'm out
i think we can all agree that we're in a
very very divisive time i think social
media is a big
factor to that me and my girlfriend
literally sitting in the same room
both on facebook and our feeds be
completely
different and what actually is happening
because of it is we're only seeing these
echo chambers where things are becoming
much more
divisive so i think what we need to
start realizing is we have to actively
start searching the other side just to
even get that perspective because
otherwise we're just going to get things
that already align
with our world views correct me on this
if i'm wrong but it's my understanding
that republicans
definitely like helped create and were
very like pro
a lot of the like tax loopholes that
especially like businesses exploit
that's definitely something that i that
i don't think is a good thing i don't
feel like the left is as intolerant as
they should be
i think that they could be able to say
have conversations not just shut up and
listen as i have to say my point
would actually do more justice because
what you're seeing is if you don't let
me talk i'm just going to show you
in the voting booth it's kind of a
tricky situation for me
because when i look here present day
there is a very massive push for
socialism specifically
it sounds beautiful on paper it sounds
great
in fact if i if i didn't know much about
socialism i'd say hey
free healthcare free school free housing
free
free free free why not i would love for
anybody
especially on the joe biden side to just
name me a country where socialism has
actually
worked and being being a mom of three
boys
and being a veteran and everything like
i feel like this is the most important
election that we have
um and i feel like trump even though
he's not perfect
he is keeping a lot of things in place
when it comes to our constitution and
our bill of rights
i want everyone to have access to
quality health care i want everyone to
have access to quality education i think
everyone deserves a home or somewhere to
live in
i think everyone deserves to have food
on the table at night i think when you
retire you should have access to
medicare i think these are very basic
level of play playing field for
everybody i listen to republicans all
the time
and i don't hear them saying they want
to do any of the things i just described
i keep hearing a lot of kind of talk
about socialist marxism blah blah blah
i don't really care what label you come
up with right i'm just saying people
deserve basic dignity in this country
but right here in new york city there's
one in five kids who are homeless
like what are we doing there's gotta be
a balance between
people who have so much money just
hoarding
billions and billions of dollars and
people suffering
because our governments at the state and
local level don't have the money to help
them
and we have people at the federal level
most of the republican party
that don't want to spend any money to
help them right we got to change
something here because everyone does
deserve access to health care
education you know earlier kind of a
climate donald trump is 70 something
years old
he doesn't have to deal with climate but
me being on staten island sitting on the
edge of the atlantic i do
this affects our home prices this is
going to affect our generation for
decades
and the longer we wait to do anything
about it the worse it gets and so i'm
i just keep looking at the republican
party waiting for one of them to say
we treat these problems seriously we see
the crisis for what it is
and here's our big bold ideas to solve
them and
i'm not hearing that i definitely just
want to commend your like passion for
the welfare of others
like that is so evident that you just
care about people like you said having
quality education having quality health
care having food on their table
um i think that shows like tremendous
compassion compassion
and i like i definitely respect that
whatever system we're talking about that
puts more
power in the hands of the government and
and has the government control
the means of production or whatever it
is i would say
empirically like when you look at when
that has been tried that has led to like
worse education it's led to worse health
care it's led to increased poverty
i'm not advocating we end capitalism
tomorrow like i don't think any
entrepreneur
who wants to start a business like
should suddenly change their plans
because of a socialist movement
all i'm saying is there's a lot of basic
guarantees we should be giving people
from the government education healthcare
etc addressing big picture problems like
climate change that require big
investment and regulation
in order to address we need those things
and there's only one party right now
that is even offering some of what we
need remember i'm a progressive i don't
think the democratic party is going far
enough
i don't think joe biden's platform goes
far enough but i know i can at least
pressure him as an activist i don't
think i can do that with the republican
party
they bring snowballs to the senate floor
to prove there isn't climate change
how am i supposed to convince them we
need to invest in more green jobs in
this country
if they don't even think the problem is
real i can't speak to
like environmental concerns as much but
definitely in terms of education and
definitely in terms of health care i
think the free market has a ton to do
with it
health insurance or health coverage is
not the same as health care
and i would also say that free education
is not the same thing as good education
so i think a really good example is
canada healthcare is free but
the quality is super duper low and if
you go to public health care in canada
if it's an emergency sometimes they'll
even refer you to a private health care
right but the difference in those things
is cost if you want to have a private
health care plan in canada
go for it i don't care but the thing is
everyone in canada has that basic right
if they need it they have it and i'm
just saying in america that should be
the same thing
you want to pay for that extravagant
school or healthcare plan
knock your socks off i don't care like
these are just basic rights we can
guarantee people it doesn't have to
replace
all these other systems you're
comfortable with let's just give people
certain rights
and then have that conversation about
how well it is or isn't going
but the brain you deal right now that's
what they want to do especially
let's talk about degree new deal right
like millions of dollars with no
actual plan the plan is simple we need
to rebuild the infrastructure in this
country to be more climate resilient
because places like right here in staten
island
get destroyed every time there is a
tropical storm
let alone another hurricane sandy so
what if we just guaranteed everyone who
wanted training and a job
whether it's here or in appalachia where
they only do coal mines
a job in making glee green products it's
literally the most
capitalistic thing the democratic party
could possibly come up with to boost our
economy
and fight climate change it's like a
win-win for everyone
trump just signed a deal where we're
going to be planting a trillion
trees trees have a very big importance
on our country
on our planet as a whole so
why you want to take away all of these
industries that are taking from the
planet
but we're going to be giving back to the
planet it doesn't work when we're doing
these things
so i just want to be honest
scientifically right like the the
reality is he can plant two million
trees but the amazon in brazil is
burning at a rate we've never
experienced in global history
and it doesn't matter how many trees we
plant in america if the planet's screwed
right at the end of the day we have to
stop putting carbon in the air and
california is a great example of a state
trees absorb carbon but we need to stop
putting it in the air to begin with
that's the problem
we can't just rely on absorption i'm
very much for the fact that republicans
need to be better on the environment
actually but you said joe earlier that
you're progressive who thinks democrats
don't go far enough i don't think
republicans go far enough
but i do think that there are some
strides that are being made he signed
the save our seas act cleaning plastic
out of the ocean
the us is currently leading the world
and reducing uh carbon emissions
and in terms of the green new deal i
feel like this is a concern that a lot
of people on the right have that this it
always starts with
something that sounds very lovely save
the planet cost was
tens of trillions of dollars so i do
agree with you that i think we should be
investing
in jobs and promoting that with the free
market but i don't think the green new
deal is the way i don't think joe
biden's plan is actually the green new
deal
so we might need to actually revisit
that subject the issue that i have too
is the republicans don't really trust
science
so at least we do look at democrats of
trying to listen to scientists and think
about what they're saying about what
could save the climate and economy
i honestly don't know what joe biden's
position is on the green new deal
anymore because on his website it
promotes the green new deal it says that
it's a great
plant so i don't know at this point if
he's for it if he's against it
he's he's sort of spoken out of the
sides of his mouth on that as a
progressive i wish he was for the green
new deal
that's my honest answer i wish he was he
has though moved on spending more
in his overall climate package it's now
a 2 trillion climate
package i know it doesn't mean a lot to
the people watching this but all i'm
saying is he is listening
he just isn't going all the way that
sometimes right-wing media portrays him
as
one of the things i want to say is when
we look at media we look at media as a
mainstream media but we don't
see social media as media and the reason
why i say that it's we can't only blame
media but at the same time
we're just retweeting articles without
doing any type of fact checking as well
we are also part of the same problem
that the mainstream media is doing every
single time we
re-retweet or share or don't actually do
content i think that's so true aka
a lot of people will complain about the
people in power and a lot of people will
complain about the government
but i think like we as everyday citizens
also also have to hold ourselves to
account
um because like we did elect the people
that are in power
um and we are like making like exactly
like you said we are sharing things on
twitter and facebook and so i do think
that the everyday citizen needs to have
a little bit more critical thinking
uh when they read something they have to
ask themselves like is this true does
this make sense
can i ask you like where does everybody
get their news sources from
i don't really watch much cable tv
because i think it's kind of
cable tv is like i think people confuse
cable tv for journalism cable tv is
predominantly personality speaking
i just assume that everybody's has their
own personal agenda and i just i use it
as a top layer and then i gotta go in
deeper to find the actual facts so
when people talk about the stock market
i'll actually go to
dow jones if they're talking about
unemployment rate i'll actually go to
you know bureau of all you guys i labor
statistics
was a great conversation this was so
refreshing to me but i know that we all
grew up in completely different
environments we have different
perspectives and everything
and i hope that as we as americans we
can just completely
accept hey this person might think
differently than me
but it doesn't mean that they're a
horrible person we've all had some type
of experience that can dictate why we
might be liberal or what i mean
why we might be conservative but at the
end of the day we're still american and
we're still valuing and listening to
each other
my encouragement though is to fellow gen
zers please please please please vote
um you know us young people get written
off as not caring and not paying
attention we don't vote blah blah blah
the best way to make everyone in
politics and in dc care about us is to
vote so i would just say to
anyone watching think for yourself do
your own research
vote for whoever the hell you want to
vote for don't let anybody tell you how
to think who to be
how to vote i would say to everybody on
here like keep doing what you're doing
the bible says he who seeks will find
and so i think those who are like truly
seeking truth will like absolutely one
day like come across it
right now we are communicating a lot
through zoom but hopefully we can
actually step away and not just
communicate
virtually but actually have
conversations that think differently
than us in our neighborhoods in our
streets
in our communities because i think we
now realize through this conversation
it doesn't really help to demonize any
side
even if we're yelling and fighting but
just say hey
i can hear you i may not agree with you
it might get hectic sometimes
but we're in this together
you